in this video we'll talk about
anaphylactic shock anaphylactic shock is
one kind of life-threatening severe
allergic reaction and it happens due to
immune system's release of certain
chemical in an uncontrolled fashion in
anaphylaxis blood pressure drops and
suddenly the airway becomes constricted
which leads to difficulty in breathing
the pulse become weak the heart rate
becomes rapid there is a nauseous
feeling and blister-like rashes
throughout the skin the immediate
treatment is an epinephrine injection
followed by a visit to emergency room
because anaphylactic shock and relapse
Within
12 hours
so let's say
what can cause anaphylactic shock
so there are certain food item such as
let's say seafood or let's say insecting
that can possibly cause anaphylactic
shock other than that there could be
certain drug or let's say anesthesia
induced anaphylactic shock as well
so let's talk about the Immunology
underline anaphylaxis
so there are cellular and molecular
components which are associated with
anaphylaxis majorly mast cell basophil
and ige antibodies are associated with
the anaphylactic reaction it's also a
type 1 hypersensitivity reaction which
is rapidly occurring
now it starts with the exposure of
allergy in one time the first exposure
at that point of time the dendritic cell
would present this antigen to the T Cell
which would eventually proliferate and
differentiate into th2 subtype
eventually th2 subtype secret cytokine
that converts naive B cell into plasma
cells that produce ige antibodies once
ige antibodies are produced after
allergen exposure these ige antibodies
can bind to the mast cells with the FC
receptors and thereby they sensitize the
mast cells for future this was the first
exposure
so after fast exposure there is no
visual symptoms nothing happens
but the problem occurs when there is a
second exposure during the second
exposure
the allergy binds to The ige
cross-linked receptors and lead to
severe degradulation of mast cells in an
uncontrolled fashion these kind of
degranulation can cause several things
most commonly bronchoconstriction when
the Airways are constricted it's
difficult to breathe less oxygen goes to
different parts of the body
then there is increased glandular
secretions smooth muscle constriction
and vasodilation dilated vessels ensures
more and more immune cells to move to
the regions and cause inflammation
anyway treatment of anaphylaxis includes
epinephrine shot in the thighs followed
by a visit to emergency room because it
can relapse within 12
hours of time so constant monitoring is
really important when somebody is
undergoing anaphylaxis anaphylaxis is
life-threatening so if somebody is
undergoing this kind of situation they
should immediately rush to the hospital
otherwise there could be a problem
you can get more notes and flash cards
in my Facebook page Instagram page all
the links are in description you can
support our Channel by super thanks you
can pay via paytm Paypal UPI thank you
see you in next video